to the memory and to the love that i
have for didier jobber comparing him to
thierry reed for big game players it's
actually unjust if we if we're comparing
didier drogba and big games we need to
be comparing him to the likes of diego
maradona the aerial really doesn't get
tirion reed doesn't get it see everyone
else
doesn't get on this list
rory
how's it going yeah good lovely to see
you let's see again well
i thought we'd be drinking champagne i
should be european champions that should
be all i drink for a year
it started already
arsenal are the biggest club in london
three
two
one
they were i think what we need to do is
reframe
the statement arsenal were once the
biggest club in london until very
recently you are the biggest club in
london they were they were
robbie i have nothing but ultimate
respect for arsenal football club and
what they have established but these
things aren't set in stone forever when
i was a kid growing up in north london
arsenal were the biggest club around in
london in north london in north london
you know
no absolutely when i was a kid that were
the case but these things evolve and
austin have now gone two decades without
a premier league title chelsea in that
time have
caught them up but if we were having
this conversation in 2001 i would have
had to fall on my sword and say that you
were correct but these things change and
two european cups two european cops i
strongly disagree i've been around the
world at arsenal it's a bigger club than
chelsea
it's a bigger club anywhere you go in
the world
and you say arsenal
people know that club we are a bigger
club than you right you've won more
things than us in recent times
but we are a bigger club than you we're
a bigger name i don't right that's what
the talk is here what's the biggest club
in london and that is arsenal but i
don't even think it's a bigger club more
fans
more fans
around the world follow us but i think
that is that in fact
fact i think more fans is that a fact i
don't think it is an official fact is it
these things are built on more than
simply a fan base these things are built
on the question is who's the bigger club
but it isn't it's not who's won the most
things recently it's like it's who's
that bigger club all of those if i if i
ask if if i say you go to spain who's
the biggest club is real madrid
or barcelona it's who's the biggest club
that's why they'll say this club's a
sleeping giant if you go in the
northeast the biggest club is newcastle
because of their fans and
their history
if you look at the history of arsenal
the fan base
arsenal are the biggest club in london
okay in the venn diagram of biggest club
most successful club there's a big grey
area there isn't it there is a there is
an overlap in terms of when arsenal were
a bigger club and when i'm agreeing i
asked them we're a bigger club part of
why they were a bigger club is because
they were more successful you win in
doubles things like that that is why
that was part of what i mean that is
what fed into you being a businessman
into it but we've always been a bigger
club than chelsea always you have always
been up until very recently up until
we're still on but the landscape of
london
we're a bit of a sleeping giant at the
moment because we haven't won nothing
for a while but we're still a bigger
club this isn't me saying it over the
case over the over the period of say one
two three years you're talking two
decades rob i'd say the only thing
you've got over us really
really when you think about it is you've
won the champions league right that's
not the only european are you are you on
the champions league but if you actually
look if you actually look at titles we
want more titles than you in our history
we've won more fa cups than you in our
history right even though we've been
going through such a bad time as you
said recently we are a bigger club okay
bigger i've been around as i said i've
been to
america when you go to america arsenal
bigger club
bigger club okay your jets less less
experience
setting why why is this if if arsenal
have this presence in the world
why have you got such a pitiful record
in european football
that's nothing to do with something to
do
by the way abramovic uh 1998 success in
europe 1971 successfully
is about to go out of yeah
but that place is flipping falling down
rob in 1998 chelsea the shed was falling
down man yummy the club just was
this close
to going out of business i could be
sitting there right now talking to a
fulham fan i mean you could be
supporting brentford i mean whether
right it was this close to going out of
business but does that reflect the size
of the club does that reflect the size
of a club shows you where you were the
second that kai havertz went round that
keeper slotted it into an empty net and
chelsea became the two-time two-time
you know this is a boxing thing two-time
european champions that upset the entire
equilibrium of london the moment you
locked you know you know what i could
see in your eyes no no it was brilliant
as i brought up kai havoc and i said it
all changed you kind of went
no i didn't do that i'm trying to stop
trying i did not do that i did not do
that the moment it all changed for you
like you know what it was
the minute the russian flew his
helicopter over london and said i want
that one
no look i don't even know who you were
rob do you know what he wanted you i
probably wanted us do you know what he
did he couldn't get it no what he wanted
was a club in london in the champions
league so this myth that chelsea were
nothing pre-abram chelsea win the
champions league you know that roman
abramovich chose who were broke roman
abramovich purchased the club that were
playing champions league football
chelsea were broke chelsea are about to
get out of business um this is this is
this is
this is true these are tropes i think
history moves things change it isn't set
in stone forever and what was once true
is that arsenal were the biggest club in
london
but
events in porto and a glorious night as
kai havertz lit up the portuguese sky
it changed and from that moment on
the london landscape never looked the
same first chelsea fan i've ever used
heard use that word what's that history
chelsea's recent success is tarnished
because they bought it
three
two
one
this is so ridiculous this is so
so annoying people people that you're
not this guy you are not this guy
really
it's one of these two it's neither of
those two it's definitely over here it's
definitely this side if you start
bringing a moralistic financial impact
on football what can you ever enjoy what
can you realistically what can you ever
enjoy do you think that newcastle fans
are not going to enjoy their incoming
success because it's bought apparently
do you think manchester united didn't
enjoy sergio aguero pinging that goal in
why because it's bought
and also what's not bought these days
why are your owners why are your owners
right
currently got a problem with newcastle
then why are they trying to stop them
from
using sponsorship deals and stuff like
that to generate more money oh why is
that i agree
with you
but you know what they got more money
than you you know what actually that's
true but it is tarnished a [ __ ] but
it's not you bought it
be real chelsea chelsea would just i'll
send it at a start you're a regular club
until the money came in
when the money is covering the champions
league the money the money the money you
acknowledge it for what it is because
regular clubs aren't playing let me ask
you this question the clubs aren't
playing are you a super club
no right
the money is no chelsea on a super club
now the money has helped to uh move you
into that stratosphere where you're now
you know super you can buy the best
players you can get i guess managing
super club biggest club in london no
you're not the biggest i never said that
stop so you're doing it so we're going
to see
super clubs here but what i'm saying is
right
you were nowhere near that until the
money came in right roman abramovich
came in you know i'm moving back to
agree because
as i said
i don't want to completely hate on it
because you did what if if the i won't
be a hypocrite if the money came in at
arsenal i'd take it i think but it does
tarnish
what you do what do you mean you
strongly disagree i disagree that it's
tarnished i think it is
look at chelsea and say you know what if
it weren't for that money you and i win
nothing but you know what did you win
but rob that kind of asks what title did
you win before the money came
with nothing for about 50 years i mean
through the night when you say nothing
title
we won the league in 55. right we're on
the league and then the money comes and
all of a sudden they win it nearly every
year chelsea
could go and buy timo verna right and
spend massive money on him right any
other club that does that he has to work
that that's like listen we've spent 50
60 million pound on him we've got to
persist with this guy chelsea can just
be like oh at the end of the season you
know what i don't know manny ain't all
that let's go and get lukaku 100 million
that's what chelsea have the ability to
do right but this is why right it's not
a level playing field right when it
comes to teams like chelsea and man city
probably soon to be newcastle because of
the level of money that they can spend
to say that the success that i've
witnessed isn't true success or isn't
isn't
relatable success or isn't genuine
success because it was in effect
purchased
is actually incorrect it isn't it isn't
the case that that is that that is the
way that it is no that's what you're
suggesting it's not how does it use it
yeah the purchase your suggestion
is always we sing to you when you come
down you bought it all you did
if arsenal were to have some success
this year
you had a huge window right you spent a
lot of money in the window
would the success if you were to be
somehow somebody spend that sort of
money let's say ben white somehow knocks
one into the to the net on the last day
of season you win the league
you're going to go potty you're going to
be the happiest you've been for two
decades i'm not you're not gonna you're
not gonna be affected by the money are
you i'm not you're not gonna be like
that's a bit different because ben white
was bored no listen i'm not saying that
right i've already said that right but
i'm saying that listen money in football
unfortunately the way football has
changed by success yeah yeah if you look
at everyone now look across every league
in europe the team that spends the most
wins with the amount of money that you
guys can spend that manchester city have
been able to spend over the past few
years it's not been a level i think it
was done on income if it was done on you
can only spend money that you generate
you know we'd all just have to watch man
united win the league every year
you can't go to bed at night
was a better big game player than
thierry henry
i love the wording of this question two
one
do you know what rob the wording of this
question is truly glorious because i
know that you are a man of principle and
i therefore know that you're going to do
the right thing here i know that you are
a man of honor a man of principle and a
man of truth
[Music]
you
i can't look at you the same way you
charlatan
because you know that he is you know
that did he
oh i feel sorry for you i love any word
in his christmas they say he's a better
player no because they know there's no
but you know
you can look on it and say
that's not strictly true because
tyrion reed
led arsenal to many titles many many
titles right
was the best player in the league
showed up week in week out i know drogba
you know he was he was a special player
for you and you know he turned up in
fa cup finals he scored any um in the
champions league final
but thierry henry was
always there in big games as well
the only one i remember that i'd say
he didn't really show up in was the
champions league final in paris but
that's that is the definition of a big
game player isn't it these games
every single big game no because they
have does they
turn up in every single big game because
every single one every single the
definition of the definition of a big
game is that there isn't every single
one
between leo messi turned up in every
single game you'd say you'd say you'd
say that lionel messi's a big game
player scoring goals for barcelona
in rome against man united you've
answered my question that's what i'm
saying so i'm saying
he turned up week in week out he won
titles we're actually what we're doing
on this question it's actually a
disgrace to didier drogba to the memory
and to the love that i have for didier
jogba comparing him to thierry already
for big game players it's actually
unjust if we if we're comparing dda
drogba and big games we need to be
comparing him to the likes of diego
maradona thierry doesn't get the aerial
reed doesn't get whatever it is
doesn't get on this list for big game
players i'd say if you're going to put
an arsenal man forward you shouldn't you
wouldn't even put him if i said
arsenal's big game player in that in
that era invincible era big game player
who's your man i think you're saying i
don't even think you're saying to
hearing i think you're saying freddie
lumber so he's saying he only turned up
in the small games i'm saying that when
you when you got to finals when par part
of being a big game player is when you
get to those when you get to the must
win the crucial the desperation make
history and he never turned up in there
no it's not about never it's about i'd
say i can remember it was it was robbery
i can remember michael owen in cardiff
robbie big game player yeah stood up
t real re arsenal lost that final cheer
everyone really is leading the line did
you win every final practically right so
you know i mean 10 goals in 10 finals
listen i'm saying to you right that
tyrion reed was one of the most
feared strikers on the planet the best
striker
in the history of the premier league one
off definitely the best one off
definitely better than dropbox but the
better that's right that's not the
question is jerry a better footballer
than didier drogbar absolutely is he
really a better big game player in the
dda drogba not even in the same league
not even not even a conversation this is
why i didn't go strongly disagree or
nothing and this is why i was kind of
hovering around because
if you
yeah you were a man of principle you
would have been up here i am a man of
power that's what i said i disagree
right i see
slightly you know i mean you've got to
go drop if you scored in that league
final he did score against us sometimes
in a couple of in some of these finals
but i can't remember him ever not
scoring against us but as i said
yeah he did you subscribe again we're
not scoring it's awesome it's got 100
record playing against a 100 record he
did use the score against us a lot um
annoyingly none of arsenal's current
first 11 would get into chelsea's first
level three
two
one
i'm genuinely trying to think of one
that i would like
i can't see where any arsenal player
would improve chelsea currently i really
can't
i'm looking forward to hearing it this
is slightly fluid for me because i need
to just think about this but there isn't
one player that i can think would 100
get in chelsea's team hit me
um thomas party
we're getting to your team
it's better than coverage and players
like he's been he's he's he's had engine
he's not he's not a cover chit she's
better than thomas party yeah for buffer
by far
yeah drunk man this year by far there is
yeah
he's a good footballer i'm not listen
i'm not disrespecting him in there there
are times when angola kante isn't picked
there are times better than thomas party
he's not better than thomas party he's
not
he is and in terms of the way that
chelsea likes to play currently it suits
kovichitch more thomas partey's injury
problems
are a real red flag yeah
he's had injury problems you know but i
think he would get in the team i don't
think do you know the person i was
thinking that you sucker
three three attacking three i mean if
everybody if we're doing everybody fit
he's not a better player than christian
pulisic is he oh no no now when they're
fit now
he's sick we're an arsenal player oh
party's never fit um
on the left side of the front three nice
amount yeah i mean he drifts but yeah
that's where he played it
there is a chance that he could
on the other side
i think um i think uh gabrielle i think
gabriel could get into your team set a
half second half yeah gabrielle could
get into your team no no no no yeah yeah
i think he could he could he could i
mean that's impossible i mean andreas
christensen and rudiger and thiago silva
oh oh just android yeah but i think he i
think
i don't know i think
i think he's as good as christensen i
think he's as um
i think rudiger has more experience than
him but i think potentially he's a
better player than rudiger as well
come on no i'm serious come off
obviously thiago silva i'm not saying
he's better you know but you know no i
mean rude christensen
no no no no no christensen bob no i'll
give him another christmas never never
this is crazy last year well you know
you wanted christensen gone until two
but it's a fluid until until thomas came
in you're wanting him out okay that i
mean
i think i think there's something real i
think chris justin's formed up until
that point one of them got was dodgy up
until that point was dodgy but
as well somebody being one he's probably
been rudely christensen have probably
been the best players for chelsea over
the past guarantee in the other marcos
alonso definitely but not over bench
hill one but marcus alonso's the guy
started for you guys
scored three goals in three games your
main guy in that left back position
under thomas
has been marcus alonso
at the start of the season it was right
so
i'd have tierney over him i don't think
tina gets in over children he does
i i'm gonna chill well he does i like
chill well
but i think i get tiny in over him as
well i feel like arsenal fans pin a lot
of hopes and love on tierney because
there's nobody else to really love no no
he's he's a lovable guy but he's a great
player it's like being at the bar at 2
am he's a great someone to love him
[Laughter]
cheers you could have had thierry henry
and ronaldo in the scene
don't remind me of that don't remind me
that in the same squad such a legend at
your place he was about to go to man
city i was here
come on like i said come on
black i called out no gallagher
it was all part the master plan